Wer entscheidet das weltweite Rennen rund
um den Hyperloop?
Die irre Nachricht: Es könnte vielleicht
Hamburg sein.
Dort gibt es nämlich einen spektakulären
Plan, wie der Hyperloop dort eingesetzt werden
kann.
Und mit dem Bau soll schon bald begonnen werden.
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich spannende Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal.
Nur dann verpasst ihr kein Video Herzlich
willkommen bei den Elon Musk Chroniken!
Das ist wirklich eine irre aber auch gar nicht
so unrealistische Geschichte.
Der Hyperloop soll nach Hamburg kommen, um
genau zu sein in den Hamburger Hafen.
Denn die Hamburger Hafengesellschaft hat etwas
ganz besonderes mit dem Hochgeschwindigkeitstransportmittel
vor.
Kurz nochmal die Idee hinter dem Hyperloop
und die ist wirklich super einfach.
Rohrpost!
Und die könnte der Magnetschwebetechnik jetzt
im Nachhinein zum Erfolg verhelfen.
Das Prinzip: Der Zug oder beim Hyperloop eine
Kapsel wird in eine´Röhre gepackt und in
der herrscht ein Vakuum bzw. ist kaum noch
Luft enthalten, ein sogenanntes Teilvakuum.
Hochleistungspumpen pumpen die Luft aus der
Röhre und erhalten das Vakuum.
Der Effekt: Es gibt keinen Luftwiderstand
mehr.
Dass Hauptproblem und DER Energiefresser jedes
schnelle Transportes ist einfach weg.
Wow.
Damit brauche ich für den Zug kaum noch Energie
ist er einmal beschleunigt.
Es sollen Solarzellen auf den Transportröhren
ausreichen, um für die Energie zu sorgen.
Und eine neue Magnetschwebetechnik ist geplant
bei der deutlich weniger Energie verbraucht
wird.
Permanentmagneten, die im sogenannten Halbach
Array angeordnet sind sollen zum einen die
Magnetkraft in die Kapsel nahezu auf null
reduzieren und im Gegenzug unten zum Transporttrack
verstärken.
Inductrack heißt die Technik die von Hyperloop
Transportation Technologies kurz Hyperloop
TT angewendet wird.
Und genau diese Technik soll in Hamburg eingesetzt
werden.
Die Hamburger Hafen und Logistik AG (HHLA)
hat laut Hamburger Abendblatt mit Hyperloop
TT eine Absichtserklärung unterzeichnet.
Demnach geht es um einen revolutionären Plan.
Die Lastwagen sollen nämlich raus aus dem
Hamburger Hafen und damit raus aus der City.
Und das ist wirklich genial.
Der Plan ist eine Station am Containerterminal
Altenwerder.
Bisher werden die Container dort per autonomem
Fahren mit selbstfahrenden Transportern, sogenannten
Automatic Guided Vehicles (AGV) zum Containerlager
transportiert.
Zukünftig sollen sie dann zur Hyperloopstation
gefahren, wo die Hyperloop-Kapseln durch computergesteuerte
Kräne mit den Containern beladen werden.
Bis zu 4100 Container könnten dann so täglich
mit unglaublichen 1200 Kilometern zu einer
Station im Hamburger Umland geschossen werden,
so Hyperloop TT laut Hamburger Abendblatt.
Dort übernehmen dann LKW die Container.
Damit werden zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe
geschlagen.
Weniger Verkehr und damit weniger Feinstaub
in Hamburgs Luft und schnellere Zustellung
von Waren.
Und mit dem Bau soll schon in zwei bis drei
Jahren begonnen werden.
Wow.
Und die Idee kann man weiterspinnen.
Denn eine solche Strecke ließ sich ja auch
verlängern.
Wir wäre es mit einer Umladestation bei Berlin,
einer im Ruhrgebiet, einer bei Stuttgart,
München, Leipzig undsoweiterundsofort.
Und die Container würden dann mit Elektro-LKW
zu ihrem Bestimmungsort gebracht werden.
Hammer!
Wir hätten ein total ökologisches und dazu
wahnsinnig schnelles Warenverteilsystem.
Wow.
Wie es mit dem Hyperloop in Deutschland weitergeht
erfahrt ihr hier.
Wenn ihr kein Video dazu verpassen wollt,
dann abonniert auch den englischen Kanal.
Auch da gibt es Videopremieren - Dafür hier
klicken. und darunter geht es weiter mit:
Competition for Elon Musk: "Flying Trains"
from China Ich freue mich auch auf dem englischen
Kanal zu sehen.
See you soon, stay tuned!